il a devancé squeeze ajouter à cette
option qui doit te hau au relief et une
vidéo sur le un sur ce prime il ya
extrêmement longtemps aujourd'hui on est
sur le deux places et partie souvenez
vous il faut qu'on aille le plus loin
possible s'enrager et ses ouvrages
romans trop il faut qu'on clique ce
bouton abandonné on le fera pas je suis
pas sûr du tout ensemble et stay ya
plein des tâches voilà et plein de trucs
qui veulent nous tuer aussi haut niveau
audi a regardé ça commence un peu un ou
où hélas quand je sens que je vais
craquer c'est insupportable mais je sais
qu'on peut le passé vous le savez à mai
mais comme le combo le plus cliqué de
l'univers ça s'est passé sur la chaîne
de squeeze je me croyais j'essaie de
faire la voix de nrj gouttes là c'est
ridicule
[ __ ] je feuilletais habile avec mes
doigts la [ __ ] dans je déteste ça je
m'en souviens ces [ __ ] de laser qui
volts à morlaàs au juste attendre en
fait qui se stabilise et tuent surtout
pour nous mais voilà on a ok j'ai
compris
voilà faut aller là en fait comme ça et
bah non facit c'est drôle à faire un
lieu pour faire radier les amants sa
surface
je pu déjà le mec qui t'énerve à 1000
kilomètres que avec bien d'être nul
qu'est ce qui se passe beach c'est quoi
sa fausse cacher là non c'est infâme ce
laser vert je le déteste
voilà tus db on trace on n'a pas le
temps
hahaha on peut pas que ma c'est celui-là
un objet de crever si on ralentit
réservé à l'effigié des chiens at on est
à huit là y'a combien des tâches bordel
de merde
ceux ci on est dans un simple immeuble
on est déjà bientôt à la fin et si on
est la tour montparnasse aveu doubiens
gabbro lena petrovna t'inquiète pas à
lui quatrième raid voilà je t'avais dit
matt inquiéter mon confort elle est là
puis là puis mourir comme une grosse
[ __ ] de biche
on peut passer thédirac là haut nous on
n'a pas le temps aussi adaptant
jean-michel pas le temps il perdure il
faut casser ce truc vert donnez moi un
sniper intervention d'un w 2 mais ça on
peut pas regarder plus que le temps
presse et accusations ce money aussi n'a
pas tendu joue au jeu de f des p o
mais le mec il stagne quoi [ __ ] ces
genres de canon que fait 362 mw2 là à
l'intervention enregistre là qu'il
camélat mis en ligne sur youtube
je suis à l'abri la au plat ah oui c'est
bon oh oui l'escem lots
sas a trouvé ça tu [ __ ] mais pourquoi
ça tout tu pourquoi ça te tue ruth pas
officiel bouton guillaume qui est
tellement énorme d'impression que tu a
cliqué dessus chaque seconde de cette
[ __ ] home vidéo
merde de ta mère j'en ai marre impute un
mythe c'est ultra rageant l'inertie elle
est dégueulasse et l'iphone qu'il c'est
bon a déclenché un bon gars howie loi
fouet des étoiles mais regardez mais ça
est ce qu'on dit celui qui voit flou et
qu'on des étoiles dans les yeux ce qui
réussit ce niveau de fdp au oui oh oui
qu'est ce que je vous avais dit pouvoir
fou avant les étoiles dans les yeux
quelle est la suite
alors je vois un laser vert et 122 tour
elles disent que ça me plaît pas du tout
j'ai compris les gars ils ont juste
rajouter une série de pics au début mais
il ya tellement d'autres cieux je les
vois plus [ __ ] y'a pas boutons des
toits il semble qu aucun bouton
abandonné en et non je suis désolé pour
les cris je vous paierai l'appareil
auditif ou para tu commences en pleine
santé tu finis avec les hémorroïdes et
kader ou avec le syndrome de la tourette
ou de la tourelle 6 étoiles qui me tue
ta vu que tout va bien se passer on au
quai m'attendent avec les insultes dont
il chausse mignonne qu'on meurt au nom
tout est si doux je t'aime petit poney
là on est en situation de forte on
arrive on fait tomber la caisse ont fait
tomber la caisse brebis tas je suis
désolé je faisais de remplacer les gros
montage par ddd autrement ne sert pas du
tout la photo de vulgarité supérieur aux
réparties points comme la caisse tombe
la caisse tombe fait deux brebis un
nouveau niveau j'adore à la la qu'est-ce
que c'est facile à excellent c'est quoi
ça ah merde c'est quoi ce truc là bas ça
rhinoceros par contre
au fond d'eau dessus excellent la blague
excellent vraiment au oui on est passé
mais de manière tellement tranquille
rien des lieux ça l'a rendu fou en bas
il est jaloux alors ça c'est quoi ces
nouveaux là ce qui se passe au vert des
mois ça aa oui je rajouter quoi un étage
avec de la lawe assez drôle un os à
l'epic malin malin attention alors ça
faire attention c'est très fourbe au nom
et vous prêts à voir le skill attention
ce quiz qu'il aux voitures gonna do
c'est pas de la petite actu va nous
faire peur mon gabon ont dû lac à snl
comme ça j'ai même entendu ronronner un
moment mais qui craint cette lave
personnes non je n'avais pas un peu plus
de temps mais pourquoi ils ont bien
raison à cet endroit mais fouette faut
être un [ __ ] de maître animal si des
japonais et des rideaux comme ça dans un
premier temps le cul de sac le sandwich
on appelle ça va avoir des bébés chauve
souris ou des bébés chauffe tout
confirmant un bébé humain mais chauve
souris ça fait quoi un humain chose on
s'amuse beaucoup dans cette vidéo
messieurs dames de tiendrait aussi
longtemps que je tiens au lit jim popp
derrière ce sanglier mondiale aux
anglais métro la pression la lèvre son
attention là la main en canoë s'ajoute
un truc qui survivent à toi tu pas donc
non non au oui on ne rien d'épique
maintenant non onana ya des pics et
maire de il ya aussi des rhinau et de
l'électricité et je peux arrêter
d'essayer virtuellement pas du tout
qu'elle connaissait retour le squeeze
qu'il en ait chouchi aux play-offs et
maintenant il y avait deux cas je vais
pas m'excuser bonus te veel même look
est blême via semaine menu ouais c'est
vraiment adorable ah ok d'erreur faut
que j'aille à appuyer et ça voilà ça va
retirer sa visite ouais voilà l on y
aura c'est quoi ça amicale ya un mais
celia demis et le savoir bientôt obama
qui appuie sur le bouton rouge et qui
ensuite bourgoin ne vous en faites pas
on va passer tuto vice quiz et on arrive
là il ya un petit trou on peut tomber
hop on active ça faut juste esquivel
rhino puisque du coup il ya un plafond
et fois qu'on l'a esquivée bon et bien
on passe au niveau d'après voilà c'était
squeeze pour l'émission à vos ce qu'ils
on est précipitée a non [ __ ] oui site
avec trop de vitesse pour les pays qui
devraient être une ouverture très
et petit haut alors ça c'était d'un
style vraiment je me lance des fleurs ou
des bouteilles en plastique c'est pareil
ahmedou jeu flamme à jets de flammes
eurent sa flamme c'est drôle ça au les
enfants comme les américains dressent
par gardant l'espoir l'espoir c'est le
regard des taux bas les couilles
j'étais pas loin de les y arriver je
sentais mon coeur il quoi se passa la
parole de taylor swift a eu michael
foeth quoi bon les gens vous pouvez non
mais à un moment il faut arrêter
non le passé alors là alors là le jeu
vers yves ajoute rose sur le jeu
pourrait pleurer station vous avez
abandonné
ouais moi qu'est ce qui se passe chez
eux ou thé à la télé on bat les couilles
avec des prix à gagner tu as gagné
essayez de fromage d'une valeur de 100 $
simone je vais pas la trouvaille je suis
posée des frais d'envoi les gentils la
fin de cette vidéo sur youtube
je suis désolé je vous aime pas que tu
mon moral me disais l'uqar est tu perds
du temps de vie arrêts n'hésitez pas là
mais la vidéo ça vous a plu
comme d'habitude dans son court terme
attendant une prochaine vidéo exactement
en quelques mots en pis
[Musique]